hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for thee I hope you guys
are all enjoying the holidays and if you
guys did see some snow that you're
having a lot of fun and enjoying the
weather
in the last video over 800 people voted
in the poll and 600 people said they
wanted to see didn't just r-cube so
today I'm going to show you a variation
of the ninja star cube that was
originally designed by Louis Simon it's
a really cool modular origami model that
has ninja star windows on all six sides
one of the cool things that you can do
is actually create an ornament out of it
just like this and hang it we'll put it
on display for everyone to see your cool
creation if you do want to make an
ornament out of it my favorite thing to
use is a binder clip but you can also
use paper clips rubber bands or even
some string so grab either three or
twelve pieces of printer paper or
origami paper whatever you like to use
and let's go just like with the small
and the large kaleidoscopes the small
and the large ninja star cubes are
modular origami models so they're made
up of identical units except with the
ninja star cubes we're going to be using
twelve instead of seven for this video
I'm going to make twelve sheets out of
three different sheets of printer paper
to make the smaller one since I think it
is a little bit nicer as an ornament but
if you want to make the larger one
you're just going to need 12 separate
square sheets from the printer paper so
let's go ahead and make the 12 squares
[Music]
now that we have 12 squares we're ready
to go
because all the units are made exactly
the same way I'll go through with you
how to make either one or two and then
you can make the rest we're going to
start out with a piece of paper that has
a fold in it by taking the upper right
corner and folding it down to the bottom
left corner and then making a sharp
crease along that edge once we unfold
the paper we now have a valley fold
going from the upper left to the bottom
right we're going to make it a mountain
fold by flipping the paper over
diagonally like this so that it's a
mountain fold then we could take the
upper left corner and fold it down to
the bottom right corner line up the two
corners
and also the edges and then we can make
a crease in the upper left piece of the
paper here on that edge once again run
your fingernail against it and then we
could unfold it you'll see we now have
an X in the paper and this fold here is
a valley-fold while the one from the
upper left to the bottom right is a
mountain fold now we could take the top
edge of the paper and fold it down to
the bottom once again
just line up the edges and then make a
crease along the top I'm gonna run my
fingernail against it just to make sure
that all the nice creases are sharp
unfold the paper and we're going to take
the top and bottom edge and fold it
directly on to the middle line just like
that once it's lined up with the middle
then once again just make a nice sharp
crease on the top and do the same with
the bottom fold it up meet the two edges
together just like that and then we can
make a nice sharp crease on the bottom
now I'm going to take both of these
edges that are folded into the middle
fold this one to the top and fold this
one to the bottom by folding these
segments in half fold it up like this
line it up and then make a crease along
the bottom there just like that run your
fingernail against it and then do the
same with the bottom fold it down line
it up with the bottom and then make a
nice sharp crease along that new fold so
now we should have a piece of paper that
looks just like this I'm going to do
something that I call a slide fold and
I'm basically just going to take this
edge here and join it up with this
middle line by sliding the paper down
just like that
so just lay it down on the table and
just bring that middle edge right down
to the center line and once it's lined
up all the way across just make a nice
sharp crease on the top so you should
have something that looks just like this
do the same with the bottom so just grab
it round off the paper a little bit just
like that and bring it up to the middle
to join with that top edge once both of
the edges are touching then you can just
make a crease on the bottom so you
should have a piece of paper that
just like this now now I'm going to take
the upper right corner and I'm going to
fold it down to the bottom so that this
right edge is on the bottom just like
that just round it off line up the edges
and then make a crease along this upper
right edge again just make sure the
creases are nice and sharp by running
your fingernail against it now I'm going
to do the same with this bottom edge I'm
going to fold this left edge all the way
to the top by taking the corner and
rounding it up just like this and
aligning this edge with the top once the
corner and edge are lined up again we're
just going to make a crease on the left
side now and just run your fingernail
against it now you can unfold both of
the corners and as you'll see we just
have these little triangles that are
also folded and we can just unfold those
also so you have these two folds in the
paper both of them are Valley folds
we're going to lift up this bottom flap
and we're going to tuck this corner into
the paper just like we just folded it so
just fold it back on that crease and
then we could refold the bottom flap
back up just like that do the same with
the bottom left corner lift up the top
flap here refold the bottom left corner
and then you can just put the flap back
down so you should have something that
looks just like this now we're going to
flip the model over and as you'll see we
have an X in the paper this line here is
actually a valley fold meaning that it's
folded up like that I'm just going to
draw on it so that you can see it a
little easier
so I'm just going to make a crease along
this line take the top edge here and
fold it to this edge by just pushing up
and just put your fingernail in there if
it's not quite folding but it should
fold pretty nicely on that line line up
the edges and then just make a crease
here along the top
and again just run your fingernail
against it so that it's nice and sharp
okay so I just creased along this line
here now what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to take this edge and
fold it over so that it lines up with
this edge right up to this corner fold
it inwards line up the edges and then
make a crease on the right now we also
have to fold this little triangle over
so just fold it over and then make a
nice sharp crease now we're going to
flip the model over and do the same
thing here
take the corner round it off a little
bit fold it in and just line up the
bottom edges just like that then just
make a crease on the right side here and
do the same with the triangle then you
can again make a nice sharp crease here
and we have completed the module just
lift this up and unfold these two little
triangles so everything is perpendicular
okay
so now you should see it looks like the
edge of a box everything is right angles
to each other so as you'll see the edges
are perpendicular and it looks just like
the edge of a box so we need to make 11
more and then I'll show you how to
interlock them
[Music]
now that we have twelve units in total
we're ready to join them up so to join
up the pieces you just need to realize
that each unit has two pockets where the
tips go into and also has two tips that
go into the pockets of the other units
so each minute will connect to four
units and each corner is made up of
three separate units now you like to use
three different colors for each corner
so that's how I'm going to do it and if
you basically take a look at two
different units here and you hold them
both the same way like this and you turn
the one on the left 90 degrees you'll
see that this little flap here if you
line it up the edge of the flap here
with the edge of the other unit like
that you'll see it needs to go right
into that pocket okay right where that
triangle is drawn is where it's going to
go all right just like that so what I
like to do is to stick this tip in first
right along the fold so if you line up
the folds like this and then you put
this tip in it'll slide right in and you
just got to give it a push now if the
creases are really sharp you might have
to lift up this flap and you'll see me
probably do that in a little bit but
there you go that's how to join up to
now again we're going to connect a red
one to these two so hold the blue one
now like this take a red one hold them
both the same way and turn the red one
like this 90 degrees to the right
now I'm going to put the red tip into
the blue pocket right there okay so I'm
gonna put this tip in like that and
slide it all the way in and give it a
pinch all right and now you'll see the
light blue one kind of wants to go right
there so just turn it and just hold it
and slide it in and it might be easier
if you kind of bend this one a little
bit that
and just pop it in like that all right
now that's the kind of tricky as far as
to get three of them together but once
you've done that you'll see that you
know it's pretty intuitive at this point
it's like a little puzzle that you need
to solve so you can go ahead and try it
on your own at this point since you know
how they connect but I'm going to go
ahead and show you how I do it now this
sets up the direction for the three
colors the light blue ones are going to
go like this
the red ones like this and the dark blue
ones like this all right so there's just
three different directions here and
that's how I'm going to connect it so if
I want to connect another red one what I
do is I look at the other red one okay
and I hold the one that I want to join
in the same direction as the other red
one now I know it needs to go over here
so I just kind of flip it like that flip
it up okay so just turn it like that and
then I put it right there
and as you'll see the ninja star shape
is kind of coming out so you know that
the red tip needs to go into the light
blue pocket right there all right
so if you slide this tip in to this
pocket by lining up these folds all
right so you see that edge right there
I'm going to line it up and then slide
that tip right underneath all the way
until it doesn't go any more just like
that
so then just give it a little pinch
right here like that
and now I'm going to create the ninja
star shape by connecting another light
blue one opposite from this one here so
again we'll take a light blue one hold
it in the same direction as this one and
say okay I'm just going to put it over
here and flip it and as you'll see that
will create the ninja star shape right
so you'll know that if you hold it here
this red one the red tip needs to go
into this pocket and the light blue tip
needs to go into the red one's pocket
there all right again just take this tip
line up the edges and
slide that corner right in like that all
the way and give it a pinch okay now
we'll turn it this way and this tip
needs to go into the red so just bring
it back slide it underneath and push it
right in then give it a little pinch and
you'll see we've created the ninja star
shape here so now we're ready to join up
another one I'm going to go with a dark
blue one here so we know that the dark
blue ones are going to go like this if
we connect a dark blue on here again to
connect another unit you just say okay
well the blue ones go in this direction
so I'm gonna hold it over the existing
blue one and then it's going to go
opposite it so I need to flip it over
like that and again you'll see that
ninja star shape kind of taking form
there alright so all you need to do is
to just slide the light blue one right
into the pocket like that okay so just
hold it back put the tip or the corner
in first line up the edge all right
slide it in all the way and give it a
little pinch now we just need to put the
blue tip right into the red pocket right
so hold it like this you might need to
just flatten out the red one like that
it'll make it a little bit easier when
you're doing a corner and just kind of
push the blue one all the way in like
that and give it a pinch now it might be
a little trickier for you
because these corners can tend to be
sharp so like I said just lift it up and
open up this flap if you need to
okay so just open it up like that slide
it in and then push it right in just
like that then give it a pinch and keep
going okay so let's create the ninja
star shape over here so this is gonna
take another light blue piece so again
to join an opposite remember it's going
to go like this over the same one and
then it's going to go opposite by
flipping it so we just need to get this
corner right in here
slide it in
and give it a pinch now again this light
blue one is gonna go in here slide it in
and give it a pinch now we could do
whichever one we want it doesn't matter
all right we have to ninja star shapes
here so let's go ahead and dark blue one
okay so we're gonna put one right here
and complete this corner all right so
again to complete the dark blue one
we hold it over the one of the existing
ones that's opposite and say okay well
it needs to go like thin put it over
here and we'll know that it needs to go
into here right into this pocket slide
it in like that and the light blue one
this is the harder part lift up the blue
slide it in just like that and give it a
good push so as you'll see the box is
kind of coming together let's do another
red one so the red one it's gonna go in
this and in that and you can just kind
of pinch the corner and again this one
is going to go into the blue one here
just like that and give it a good pinch
all right so it's coming together let's
do another light blue one right here so
the light blue one light blue one like
that over the same light blue one and
then flip it you know it's gonna go just
like that so again I like to put the tip
in first to the one I'm joining right in
like that line up the edges and push it
all the way into that pocket then it's
gonna be a little tricky here but if we
put this tip in first by folding it a
little just like that and just work it
in there you'll eventually get it you
gotta you're gonna have to definitely
work at it but you'll get it and just
pinch it right on those corners like
that so we just have two left and you'll
see the red one is going to go here and
then we have the last dark blue one
going here so remember the Reds are
going like this red flip it all right so
we know that the red one's going to go
here like this so again you'll see the
ninja star shape slide it in here
okay it'll be easier if you just kind of
open up that pocket a little bit slide
it in all the way and give it a good
pinch now this one is going to go in
here open up that flap if you have a lot
of trouble just like that and slide it
in there you go now you'll see that the
red tip is going to go into the light
blue pocket right there so slide it in
line up the edges the folded edges like
that you see and just get that right
underneath and actually it works better
like that
you see if you kind of get the folds
overlapping first sludd should slide
right in actually that's probably easier
and now the last one is the dark blue
one which is gonna go right here I'm
going to take the light blue first and
just slide it underneath the dark blue
right into that pocket that it needs to
go in right there to complete the ninja
star shape put it right in line up the
edges and push it in okay then we just
need to connect all four points so this
one don't give up here it's gonna get a
little bit tricky
alright that's in so just flatten it out
there and then here let's put the red
one in make sure it's over on top okay
and you'll see that's how that's gonna
go so just slide it in like that done
and the last one if you kind of get this
tip underneath the flap come on don't go
up let me now come on last one
oh I knew you were gonna be trouble ah
there we go
all right and give it a squeeze and
there you go you have completed the
ninja star cube now let's make it into
an ornament the easiest way that I know
of to make it into an ornament is to
take one of these one and a quarter inch
binder clips and all you need to do is
to basically just pop one of these
things out all right so you just kind of
squeeze it here like this pop out one of
these and all you need to do is to
basically just insert it into the corner
like this so you gotta kind of squeeze
it a little that insert it into the
corner that's it you could do the kind
of same thing with a paperclip or you
can take a string and kind of wrap it
there but it makes a really nice
ornament I think I think it looks really
cool and of course the one with green
and red also is very holiday like so I
hope you guys enjoyed the tutorial and
be sure to give it a thumbs up down
below oh man I'm getting sick thank you
guys very much for watching the video I
hope you enjoy it as you could probably
see my energy started to go downhill
towards the end and it was because it's
cold out and my nose is getting a little
bit runny so I've been training some cup
of noodles I hope you did like the video
and if you did please give me a thumbs
up down below don't forget to subscribe
by pushing the little button and the
notification bell as far as what I may
show next I have some ideas a lot of
people did want to see the flapping
dragon so let me know if you want to see
that I will put a pole up also I finally
did the magic ball mini magic ball giant
mini magic ball whatever you want to
call it and the regular size mini magic
ball but I don't want to teach if you
vote for the magic ball I'm gonna make
it a two-hour tutorial 5 hour tutorial a
lot of people did like the Kaleidoscope
so maybe you would want to see the
fireworks or maybe an easy stunt glider
let me know vote in the poll and leave
me a comment below and thanks again for
watching and I'll see you next time